présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues une nouvelle expression
c'est donc imposée dans le débat public
le 0 artificialisation net sous une
apparence assez technique voire
technocratique ce terme recouvre une
réalité qui s'impose d'ores et déjà au
territoire et affectera peu à peu les
modes de vie de nos concitoyens nous
avons approuvé cet objectif il y a 2 ans
dans la loi climat et résilience et nous
le nous nous le remettons pas en cause
pardon aujourd'hui car l'enjeu du
changement climatique et plus que jamais
actuelle toutefois nous sommes à
l'écoute des habitants et des élus et
depuis des mois nous alertons sur les
difficultés pratiques auxquelles ils
font face dans la mise en œuvre des
dispositions de la loi climat résilience
c'est pour cela que la commission
spéciale vous présente aujourd'hui un
texte qui est issu de 18 mois de
réflexion collective depuis l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi climat résilience il a
été rédigé par une mission qui
réunissait quatre commissions
permanentes et qu'à travailler au-delà
des clivages politiques traditionnels
notre commission a poursuivi le travail
dans des délais contraints et parvenus
au texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
en rendant ces dispositions plus
opérationnels sans en modifier l'esprit
général c'est donc un travail de fond
qui a été mené bien dans la tradition
d'écoute qui est la marque de fabrique
du Sénat et je vais à mon tour en
remercier une nouvelle fois l'ensemble
des membres de la Commission spéciale
sur tous les bancs de cette émission a
commencé par notre présidente dans le
travail a été essentiel et de
compétences une fois de plus reconnues
ce qui a favorisé l'atteinte d'un très
large consensus merci Valérie pourtant
le texte que nous vous présentons a été
parfois présenté de manière un peu
caricaturale non il ne remet pas en
cause les dates cibles de 2031 et 2050
fixé par la loi climat et résilience il
a juste seulement les dates
intermédiaires d'ici à 2031 afin de
rendre plus opérationnels le calendrier
de modification des documents
d'urbanisme non la définition des grands
projets retenus par la proposition de
loi ne conduit pas un abandon des
ambitions de réduction de
l'artificialisation au contraire il
responsabilise les acteurs non seulement
les régions mais aussi l'État lui-même
la proposition de mutualisation à
l'inverse la responsabilité en la
faisant peser sur des régions qui ne
sont pas à l'origine de ces projets et
qui ne bénéficient pas de leur retomber
le texte présenté par la commission
spéciale n'est pas seulement une mesure
de justice pour les régions en créant
une incitation à réduire
l'artificialisation des grands projets
je crois qu'il renforcent les chances
d'atteindre réellement les objectifs de
sobriété foncière non la garantie du
droit à l'hectare n'ajoute pas 35000
hectares à l'artificialisation des sols
en France c'est sans doute le chiffre le
plus contestable qui a été avancé
d'abord ce droit reste comptabilisé dans
l'enveloppe régional donc il ne porte
pas du tout atteinte aux objectifs de
2031 et de 2050 c'est seulement une
répartition différente des droits à
construire en outre la garantie rurale
comme toute garantie n'est activée qu'en
cas de nécessité
c'est seulement pour une minorité de
communes les plus rurales en général
qu'elle aura un effet des communes qui
n'ont pas forcément eu beaucoup de
projets depuis 2011 mais qui est
précisément pour cette raison pourrait
en avoir quelques-uns dans les années à
venir au total c'est 9200 hectares
environ qu'il faudra répartir
différemment entre les communes soit
7,5% du total je suis prêt à parier que
cette garantie rurale aura en réalité un
effet positif sur l'atteinte des
objectifs zan car elle ne sera pas
consommée par toutes les communes
ces mesures ont un point commun
faciliter la mise en oeuvre des
objectifs zan c'est bien ce qui est
inscrit dans l'intitulé de la
proposition de loi qui précise d'autre
part au cœur des territoires
car il n'y a rien de plus territorial
que la mise en oeuvre des objectifs de
sobriété foncières rien ne sera fait
sans les élus rien non plus ne devrait
être fait contre eux car ils
représentent tout simplement les
habitants ils sont les mieux à même
d'apprécier l'ensemble des besoins d'un
territoire c'est pourquoi le texte
cherche à leur apporter des outils
indispensables je pense à la conférence
régionale
de gouvernance de zan car de nombreuses
communes avaient ressenti que leurs
paroles n'avait pas pu être entendue
dans le fonctionnement actuel des
conférences des scottes la commission
spéciale a en effet amélioré le
fonctionnement afin de répondre à
certaines des objections qui avaient été
faites et l'examen en séance permettra
sans doute d'améliorer encore ce
dispositif je pense aussi et surtout aux
outils juridiques apportés par la
proposition de loi le sursis est statué
le droit de préemption et le motif de
refus d'autorisation d'urbanisme
spécifique aux enjeux de lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols la création
ou le renforcement de ces outils ont été
largement salués lors des auditions que
nous avons conduites l'accès aux données
est également un enjeu essentiel les
élus dans bien des territoires que celle
fournies par l'État sont insuffisantes
et est important qu'ils puissent
utiliser celle qui proviennent des
observatoires locaux je pense enfin à la
prise en compte des spécificités de
certains territoires par exemple ce
soumis au recul du trait de côte ainsi
qu'à la prise en compte des efforts
passés de sobriété française les débats
restent réels sur cette un sujet Jean
distinguerai deux monsieur le ministre
s'agissant de la nomenclature des
espaces artificialisés nous avons
approuvé la souplesse à portée par le
texte qui permet aux communes et EPCI de
délimiter dans leur document d'urbanisme
des périmètres au sein desquels
l'artificialisation des surfaces
herbacées n'est pas décompter car les
appréciations varient selon les lieux
dernier point et non des moindres
l'articulation entre les stradettes et
les documents d'urbanisme le stradette
n'est pas un document d'urbanisme nous
pensons nécessaires d'indiquer
explicitement qui s'appliquent dans un
rapport de prise en compte et non de
compatibilité l'acceptabilité des
objectifs zan dans les territoires
passent encore une fois par la
responsabilisation de l'ensemble des
acteurs en particulier ceux à qui la loi
attribue la compétence en urbanisme et
non par la verticalité
bien que la politique de sobriété
foncière soit imposée et pilotée au
niveau national et régional les élus
locaux sont en première ligne ils n'ont
pas bénéficié d'un soutien suffisant
malgré la nouveauté et la complexité des
enjeux c'est à nous de leur donner les
moyens et les outils pour mettre en
oeuvre cette politique la mise en œuvre
de la loi climat et résilience doit
respecter les compétences et
l'intelligence collective de nos
collectivités elle ne peut nous imposer
d'organiser leur sous développement
l'objectif est bien de concilier la
sobriété foncière avec le développement
harmonieux le gouvernement nous adore
c'est déjà écouter sur plusieurs points
il a reconnu que l'artificialisation
induite par les grands projets ne
pouvait pas être comptabilisés
intégralement sur les droits à
construire de la région dans laquelle
ils sont implantés il a admis une
évolution du calendrier et la nécessité
de préserver des possibilités de
construire minimales dans des communes
rurales il faut reconnaître et saluer
ses avancées mais disons-le monsieur le
ministre ce n'est pas encore assez je
sais que vous avez identifié les enjeux
posés par le zanne dans les territoires
mais nous essaierons de vous convaincre
que les réponses que vous proposez sont
encore insuffisantes cette proposition
de loi à vocation à poursuivre sa
navette jusqu'au bout avec ce texte le
Sénat donne l'occasion d'ajuster les
conditions de mise en oeuvre de la loi
et le gouvernement l'a bien compris en
déclarant la procédure accélérée nous
vous encourageons à favoriser à présent
l'inscription la plus rapide possible
lors du jour à l'Assemblée nationale en
effet il faut aller vite ce texte
s'inscrit dans un double calendrier
celui de la révision des stratède qui
doit s'achever pour le mois d'avril 2024
et celui de la mise en œuvre du moins de
50 % il est essentiel de rendre la loi
lisible opérationnelle adaptée aux
réalités de nos collectivités voilà bien
l'objet du texte présenté aujourd'hui
par la commission spéciale je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]